RIA SYMONDS: I've chosen NUMBER
153, or 153, because
it's very special to
me, because it's a
narcissistic number.
To be a narcissist, you
need to basically be
in love with yourself.
And 153 is in love with itself
because it has a mathematical
property which makes it so.
MALE SPEAKER: While you're
fixing your hair there, can I
ask you, are you a narcissist?
RIA SYMONDS: I think all
mathematicians are a little
bit of a narcissist.
We're all in love
with ourselves.
So, rubbish pen.
1, can I change pens?
5, 3.
MALE SPEAKER: I can't see
why that number's
in love with itself.
RIA SYMONDS: Hang on.
Now, depending on how many
digits the number has, so this
has one, two, three digits,
I'm going to take each of
those digits and raise
it to that number.
1 to the power of 3.
5 to the power of 3, and
3 to the power of 3.
And I'm going to add
those together.
So I've got 1 cubed.
1 cubed is pretty simple.
It's 1.
5 cubed, 125.
That requires a little bit more
mathematical knowledge.
3 cubed is 27.
So we add them up.
Lo and behold, we'll get
1 add 125 is 126.
Add on 27, and we get 153,
a number that is
in love with itself.
Let me give you a four-digit
narcissistic number.
8,208.
OK, this time, there are
four digits to a
narcissistic number.
So 4's the important part.
That's what we're going to raise
each of these numbers
to, the power.
So let's take 8 to the power of
4, 2 to the power of 4, 0
to the power of 4, and 8 again
to the power of 4.
Add these up in your head, or
using a trusty calculator, lo
and behold, you get 8,208.
Check it at home.
It's the same number.
It's in love with itself.
MALE SPEAKER: Is this
useful or important?
Or is this just fun
and games for you?
RIA SYMONDS: This is
just fun and games.
This is just one area of why
math is so brilliant.
And there is a limit.
There are 88 narcissistic
numbers, to be precise.
The largest is a very
big number that I
can't actually say.
There's too many things.
But the most it has is 39
places to that number.
So you can't get any numbers
bigger than 39
numbers within it.